when you make money the goal you become
[ __ ] vulnerable mentally you become
vulnerable [ __ ] mentally they put
[ __ ] things on a pedestal they their
insecurities of their status is driving
them and that's what the and plenty of
people can be successful through deep
insecurity but they're not happy [ __ ]
people let there be no [ __ ] confusion
on this team with garyvee i'm not
talking about successful
entrepreneurship i'm talking successful
life
absolutely yep i agree with you
i think the market
is
is ripe
for a place like this to when i think
about all the people moving to miami or
puerto rico or yeah i think um
you know the remote worker
the virtual worker
the
there's just so many inherent advantages
that dubai has
to really make a play
do you think the best play
could be in the
dow space or defy or nfd or my my
intuition is that nft is the most
lucrative space because i think
similar to social media and consumer
internet it's inherently
all-encompassing you know i think you're
gonna i think you'll see the biggest
movement
in
how consumers everybody interacts with
it i think the nft space is incredibly
lucrative but don't you think there's a
barrier for entry that text is hard of
course but the tech is hard and
everything i mean
understanding how to be part of a dao
it has you know it's just all new i mean
i think for me i got lucky my career
started when people didn't know how to
use email
and so
i've seen
things go from this is hard
to this is easy i i bring up to a lot of
friends i'm like look
this is all hard now custodial
non-custodial all this stuff i'm like
you used to have to be a programmer to
get on the internet and then marc
andreessen created a browser and the
world changed and i think in next five
years all of this will be incredibly
happening on the back end right now it's
just so new
and so yeah i think there's a barrier of
entry but if you look at
how many people have been willing to
fight through that barrier to be a part
of this space
in such a short period of time
um
i think we'll see a lot more uh
a lot more adoption very quickly yeah if
you're in a position where your parents
aren't
completely stopping you from doing
things on the side and saying no you
can't you
you were forbidden you must only study
if you're lucky enough that you can
do both i would tell you that you have
plenty of time
in front of you yeah what you want but i
do think the sooner you can start
tasting
you know drop shipping
uh influencer marketing nft
cryptocurrency all this stuff looks easy
on paper
it's good in theory but then when you do
it
it's much harder than people think and i
think the sooner you can
taste
the ups and the downs
it's kind of like exercising you'll be
more prepared for when you do it
full-time it's like prepping for a fight
you'll be ready for the fight so i think
you know are you are you in a position
where
you can start doing some of this stuff
on the side
um i think i can what i spoke to my dad
about was doing this in summer
um and and one of my and my dad had a a
meeting with the with an american
businessman
uh and he um
he's based in arizona and
he has a lot of friends and real estate
and everything and he came to our house
a week ago and i have um plans to go and
visit them in arizona and
and expand my knowledge about because
i'm really interested in real estate as
well doing real estate in the future so
so i basically planned my whole summer
to do that and um
and what what my my dad tells me a lot
is that he feels that i'm lazy and i
don't disagree with him
uh i can be i have the tendency to be
lazy but i also
you're lazy because you're disinterested
exactly exactly 100 when i was 13 to 18
i was told by
many many people that i was lazy they
just happened to be people that
were at school
you know
yeah and maybe my grandma sometimes
around the house because i didn't want
to hang a picture but
you know
i uh you know it makes me laugh so much
because people thought i was lazy yet my
life's destiny was to be synonymous with
work ethic
yeah
like i
i really feel like if i had something
interesting like when i watch all those
videos about uh business and marketing
and real estate i expand like three like
hours like just just watching and just
listening and it's so interesting and
i'm so captivated in the moment but as
soon as i switch back to my chemistry
class and they start talking about all
this other stuff like in two minutes i'm
so disinterested
so uninterested in whatever they're
talking about i lived your life my
friend i understand i i it got so bad
for me that i started bringing wine
magazines to school
and i would read them in the middle of
class
like literally
i i basically realized something
i realized that my high school
was more interested in me passing
because they were going for a blue
ribbon status in new jersey
which required everybody graduating
i realized that i could
as long as i showed up for school
that i was going to pass
and the second i realized that
i
basically
read wine magazines in class or fooled
around or daydreamed or doodled yeah or
whatever you know i i think the key here
is
perspective one
you're going to have you're not missing
out today it's
nfts tomorrow it's vr the next day it's
something that not the three of us could
even imagine so i think you've got to
make sure that you don't have anxiety of
missing out
once you have a good relationship with
that
what you need to do is just focus on
learning as much as you can
around the things that you're passionate
about
you know ultimately
your parents will
be okay no matter what as long as you're
healthy and happy
but you might have to have a little bit
of pain in between now and that success
if you love skiing hey
if you love tea
hey
if you love the yankees
you have to start making content around
that
and then
you can lay your business on top of it
you love the yankees like everybody
who's home right now [ __ ] stuck
start a podcast a youtube show and
instagram around your favorite thing
make videos about if you love an nfl
team you're set there's free agencies
there's things to talk about become your
local sportscaster take your hotcakes
post and then after a year of that maybe
get to a place where somebody wants to
sponsor your yankees podcast the yankee
shop for 2500 a month and you start
building you start building it's about
building a business around something
that makes you happy not the business
that you think is going to make you the
most money do you know why everybody's
into
cryptocurrency and cannabis and social
media and real estate and and
wall street selling money
money
and
and when you make money the goal you
become [ __ ] vulnerable mentally you
become vulnerable [ __ ] mentally i
know [ __ ] unlimited people that
[ __ ] went into something actually
made the money but they [ __ ] hate it
and three years at first they needed the
money but three years in now they've got
the money and now it's [ __ ] handcuffs
because they need the money because now
they've started spending it people who
don't have anything when they get money
then they start buying dumb [ __ ]
you're right because that's part of the
whole equation of the psychology of not
coming from anything and getting money
they want the money not for stability
and peace of mind they want the money
for the bmw that they saw the rich
people don't when they walked across the
highway from the trailer park to go to
the mall and like one day i'm gonna have
one of those they put [ __ ] things on
a pedestal they their insecurities of
their status is driving them and that
and plenty of people can be successful
through deep insecurity but they're not
happy [ __ ] people let there be no
[ __ ] fusion on this team with garyvee
i'm not talking about successful
entrepreneurship i'm talking successful
life
absolutely yep i agree with you
very clear if you read or watch anything
for even more than five minutes that i
want people to be happy and be
self-aware
do i believe that work ethic
is a foundational piece of success yes i
do
do i want anybody ever to work so much
that they get depressed of course not i
you know i never think that money is the
driver and so i think i think whether
it's lazy headline reading or not doing
homework
yeah it's it's not been it's not been
the most fun to get dragged into no yeah
i was like oh i found reading
no and there's so many people who are
proof of the words that you say me
included um
so so yeah it's like
a there's a byproduct of success
you know
where
people will you know
hustle porn's a term leverage poor is a
term
leveragepreneur is when you're using
other people to build yourself up at the
cost of the other person
and you know i think that though you
know as you get bigger people will
leverage you and i'm okay with that
because the truth always wins in the end
and
you know i know the body of work that i
put out my intent
um and if you want to
clip
one thing or one
definitive statement from one talk
without the context of the whole thing
of course you can say anybody says
anything but the reality is is that you
know i uh i believe work ethic is
important if you want to achieve
hyperbolic success i don't want to tell
people how to be happy yeah so why are
you telling me how i should be happy
uh and there's plenty of people that are
super depressed that work 40 hours a
week like it's just hyperbolized link
baiting leverage preneuring and i'm okay
with that but at the same token it's
important not to not take other people's
points of view into account and i'm i'm
in a constant you know focus of that as
well what do you feel like you've
mastered and what do you feel like
you're still learning second question
um what am i i'm still learning about
myself you know in the new book i talk
about candor i mean it it took me
you know what's crazy for people
watching this is gary v
biggest strength this candor
but i'm not talking to anybody i'm
talking to the world and thus i'm not
hurting dustin's feeling where johnny's
feelings or susan's feelings
um as an operator for 20-plus years i
did everything i could
to fix a situation
without telling somebody they stunk are
you conflict-avoidant
yes
i'm
but what made me build big businesses
was not at 1201
okay got it yeah at 11 59 i was yes at
1201 i wasn't i would always do the
thing that the business needed you had
to get you got it done but it was so
cute it's it was so and what i learned
and why i wrote about it was it was so
sloppy from 10 30 p.m to 12 00 and the
angst and then and so what would happen
you know really how it started was i was
reading a facebook group of former
employees and there was enough people in
there that were not
loving me
and i kind of just like read it and
looked at it and i was like this is a
problem it's time i fix this i know who
i am i have no ill will i only have deep
love for my employees i don't value the
money enough to be
why am i in this situation where these
people don't feel great towards me and
they've worked for me it's one thing
when like johnnypants47 leaves a comment
says you're full of [ __ ] yeah yeah that
means nothing you're like shut up yeah
in the same way that somebody says
you're the goat and they don't know you
you can't go high or low if you don't
know somebody but when i'm reading
somebody who works for me for 19 months
and i feel like i had interactions with
them and i know how i run vayner and
they're like [ __ ] gary i'm like [ __ ] and
when i kind of really dissected it all
of the people that were not pumped all
had sloppy exits whether
we
slash i
got them to quit
through them
or they were pushed out
on thursday i would see them in the hall
and be like karen keep rocking it and on
monday we're like you got to go
and like that was a real shortcoming and
so i talk a lot about it and i talk
about how i put the word kind in front
of candor and it shifted everything for
me three four years ago i just i just
can deal with it more i can deliver it
more um
and
and i practice it more and
and it's made substantial i mean vaynerx
it's revenue
business the p l is dramatically
stronger today because its ceo got
better at candy yeah it trickled down
my greatest belief is that a leader's
number one goal is to eliminate fear
hence why it was hard for me to say
sally you know you're really not doing
well and we're going to need to get this
better my thought was sally leaves my
office
goes and gets upset johnny johnny leaves
my office goes and gets upset gets
scared goes on linkedin and starts up
there shit's all over yeah like i feel
like candor leads to fear
and that's how i saw it for a long time
and that's wrong
but but the reason i don't call it
candor in the book and call it kind
candor is what i know for fact is over
the last 25 years i've witnessed
unlimited inside of my companies or the
hundreds of companies i've invested in
that people use candor as an excuse to
be mean
managers and bosses use well i'm just
helping you but they [ __ ] all over you
yeah their bedside manners are atrocious
and even though they're helping you you
leave
you know stunned demotivated shook and
you're out the door and i think it's
time once and for all that we talk about
what it is to
be a leader and build a big business and
i don't think nice guys finish last
[Music]